[Music]
this is david deutschman
this is david deutschman that's brother
for the last 12 years david has held
over 1200 babies at scottish rite
hospital hey david when can i raise my
voice after the titles appear
[Music]
at children's healthcare of atlanta
you'll find david volunteering as a baby
buddy a person that spends time holding
babies who are delivered prematurely or
requires special medical attention when
i first came to work for the hospital
they gave me a little baby to hold and
the child life person walked by and said
hey you hold babies i've got a job for
you and i just loved it i became
nicknamed by a few nurses as the baby
whisperer all right buddy i'd be given a
baby who was screaming crying
[Music]
you'd be amazed how quickly they can
calm down
because the babies stay in the hospital
for a long period of time most parents
can't stick around mainly because their
maternity leave runs out or they have
other kids at home that's where david
comes in david has gone on to hold
countless babies in the neonatal
intensive care unit providing not only
companionship but other medical benefits
as well just ask nurse angie we find
that holding also can help mitigate some
pain so when our babies have heel sticks
done and they're being held they react
so much better than when they're not
held
david has done this for so long now when
he takes a baby into his arms you can
see the baby relax because david's so
relaxed so you feel the baby's in good
hands
if you're a retiree i would say to you
get off your butt and do something
volunteer doing something and there are
a lot of different ways of doing it
doesn't have to be in a children's
hospital
i know it meant a lot to the moms and
the dads too but what it meant for me
i really feel that
i'm the one who benefited
[Music]
you